parce que en même temps on va jouer
voilà parce que on avait envie avant les
vacances se dire tiens
les jeux c'est pas comme pour les petits
c'est aussi pour les grands donc on y va
avec alex qu'est ce que vous m'avez
sélectionné déjà c'est pas que pour eux
c'est pas que pour les petits et puis
aussi c'est pas que pour les moments on
peut partir en vacances avec des jeux
parce que il ya plein de moments où on
va devoir occuper un peu les enfants par
exemple quand un des parents on va faire
l'interminable queue au glacier du coin
vous savez grands-parents les longues
heures de train c'est pareil un petit
jeu c'est pratique et puis pour
communiquer avec les copains de les
copains de hollandais du camping imbert
rien de tel qu'un bon vieux un bon jeu
de société et les hollandaises donc moi
je vous ai apporté des tout petits jeux
des tout petits jeux on commence par
plus partie du parti
et oui pelouse par toulouse parce que
c'est une piscine où on joue on joue
autour d'une piscine des temps ça fait
bien longtemps vous n'avez pas vu chez
nous et on joue autour d'une piscine
chacun va prendre un pion va le déplacer
du chiffre qui est indiquée en dessous
d'accord et il va se déplacer d'une case
et va faire tomber les autres pions qui
sont autour de la piscine dans la
piscine le but du jeu chacun joue une
couleur secrète
le but du jeu est le dernier à les
dernières couleurs représenter autour de
la piscine son gros avantage c'est que
la boîte c'est ça il n'y a pas de mise
en place autour on le prend dans le sac
on sort on met des pions et anjou et
alors je vais vous dire c'est très joli
lavaud petits chiffres que vous mettez
de soum après tout vous pouvez les
appeler vous plutôt ordonné de qui donc
oui vu par exemple je voyais bien le
slip léopard là il me semble je les
appelais pascal la semaine dernière avec
mes enfants ça c'est loi note adopte la
vie nomade dans la piscine sabrina c'est
très bien entre trois et six joueurs à
partir de 6 ans ça passe c'est les
parties de cinq jours 5 minutes 10
minutes grands axes c'est génial voilà
pour occuper le temps qu'on vient entre
10 et 15 euros
ok voilà je mets tous les jeux tous les
jeux ici sont des petits jeux qui coûte
entre 10 et 15 euros
c'est le principe c'est de se faire
plaisir à petit prix ensuite eh bien
imaginez vous au retour de vos vacances
les animaux aient pris le pouvoir ils
ont détruit le règne animal et bain avec
argh
c'est une histoire qui prend vie
parce que toi les animaux il leur faut
que 24 karts argue ça s'appelle camargue
animals reebok
au fait le buzz en france les anime la
révolte des animaux contre les humains
il leur faut que 24 karts le but du jeu
c'est d'assemblée deux bombes animal
pour mettre fin au règne humain mais on
a des petits animaux qui sont des
traîtres au règne animal et qui vont
empêcher justement les animaux de
prendre le pouvoir c'est pareil c'est un
petit jeu qui est très simple on le
prend en main en deux trois minutes
c'est à partir de 8 ans on va dire à
partir de deux joueurs jusqu'à 4 joueurs
et ça dure dix à quinze minutes c'est
pareil c'est que 24 cartes donc dans un
sac ça tiens ça tient vraiment pas grand
chose comme place les cartes vertes et
des cartes trois territoires il ya le
laboratoire la maison et le jardin
d'hiver ce terrain d'opération pour les
animaux il est sympa celui là je vous ai
reconnu tiens ça c'est cyril qui est aux
manettes aujourd'hui qu'ils réalisent
j'ai toute l'équipe là j'ai toute
l'équipe audi dont belgique okotie auger
coco ho là là j'ai alain là ici non mais
franchement en fait ne pas citer toutes
équipées du monde les dessins sont super
sympas c'est vraiment un super jeu c'est
pareil c'est entre 10 et 15 euros
c'est un tout petit jeu qui prend pas de
place qui joue très bien enfin voila
c'est que du que du bonheur que du
bolchoï agira d heure d'explications
c'est ça qui est bien en vacances
et puis si vous n'avez rien compris
comme moi c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave cherchez vous allez sur la page
france 3 franche comté on voit là on
vous retrouve les bons plans bon il ya
aussi un petit truc c'est que des fois
quand on laisse nos animaux de compagnie
à la charge de notre charmante voisine
on revient de vacances et on trouve un
petit une petite délicatesse
signe du mécontentement des animaux un
pas de la wattine jérôme au milieu du
salon la salle soit une petite nature et
ben c'est justement le principe de goût
did it qui café en français ou en fait
on va avoir chacun des animaux en cas en
main et on va devoir les disculper de
pour savoir qui a fait au milieu du
salon
c'est à dire qu parlons clair ça c'est
du caca voilà et donc sur des pâtes et
de kaka l'arrêté de kaka est en fait il
faut savoir qui va devoir nettoyer le
cac a donc en fait chacun son tour
on va devoir disculper ces animaux en
disant ce n'est pas ma tortue qui a fait
au milieu du salon
mais je pense que c'est un poisson rouge
et la fois être le premier à mettre son
poisson rouge etc
c'est très simple à la sorte qu'au bout
d'un moment il faut jouer la mémoire il
faut savoir qui a joué comme quoi comme
carte parce que si personne n'a de
cartes qui répondent à la description
c'est vous qui ramasse et le cacao voilà
c'est un peu voilà c'est un peu pile
kaka moi j'ai une question à vous de
découvrir peut-être à notre jeu puis
avoir aussi d'aller découvrir fabienne
est ce que vous savez combien de boîtes
de jeux sont vendus chaque année en
france ou alors la façon très technique
je sais pas je dirais un million a
beaucoup plus 112 millions 112 millions
et je peux même vous dire que quelques
jeunes se sont lancés dans l'aventuré
on va regarder ensemble parce que ils
sont très très forts ces jeunes et vous
pourrez dire tiens le jeu auquel je joue
c'est injuste bourgogne franche comté
ont regardé puis on revient ensemble
ensemble c'est mieux le jeu de société
l'un des loisirs préférés des français
on va jouer tous ensemble sur les mêmes
mots on cache la première carte d'un
retour au hasard le premier joueur
pourrait par exemple poser en se disant
on va créer lecture lecteurs au moment
où vous posez une carte il faut toujours
penser à un mot qui commence par les
maîtres qui sont sur la table mais pour
certains cela représente beaucoup de
travail et d'espérance kara et yoann
viennent de créer un jeu de lettres
destinées à toute la famille tous leurs
temps libres y passe ses deux amis
d'enfance dijonnais écument les
festivals partout en france pour le
faire découvrir
l'opération séduction fonctionne plutôt
bien déjà mille boîtes vendues en
l'espace de quatre mois voir que les
gens s'amusent avec quelque chose qu'on
a créé de a à z
vraiment on est parti de rien on est
parti d'un bout de papier à écrire des
idées jusqu'à la boîte final c'est une
formation qui a été extraordinaire
passer par la case départ et toucher 20
milles ça c'est au monopoly dans la
vraie vie ce sont les deux copains qui
ont investi 20 mille euros pour la
sortie de leur jeu ils sont encore loin
d'être rentrés dans leurs frais
mais kara et yoann voit grand ils ont
également monté leur maison d'édition
dans leurs cartons une kérosène l'idée
de jeu dont certaines sont déjà au stade
du prototype
c'est une passion on va dire qu'on a
voulu monter en société puisque oui on a
nos jobs respectifs
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui on peut
pas se payer avec un seul jeu ça c'est
si ça fait un énorme carton où elle et
on s'est même pas 5% des jeux qui
sortent par an mais à voir - dont on
veut que les bénéfices des premiers jeux
nous servent à créer nouveau jeu pour
qu'on puisse avoir le plus grand
catalogue possible pour ce que pour que
derrière on puisse voilà en vivre
on aimerait un jour environ en france le
marché du jeu de société explose depuis
dix ans il a dépassé le cercle des
enfants et des initiés mais les auteurs
sont les moins bien rémunérés
seulement 2% du prix d'une boîte monter
sa maison d'édition peut donc se révéler
intéressant encore faut-il parvenir à
faire sa place dans un secteur dominé
par une poignée de géants historiques et
très concurrentielles 900 à 1000 jeu
sort chaque année en france
et tous ne trouvent pas leur public
belleneuve près de dijon
derrière la façade de cette bâtisse une
maison d'édition qui a généré huit cent
cinquante mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires l'an dernier l'entreprise a
édité 12 jeux dont certains se sont
écoulés à 30000 exemplaires non
seulement en france mais aussi en europe
au japon ou encore au canada
un succès bâti là encore par une bande
de copains passionnés bénévoles qui crée
un jeu sur le thème des zombies
cinq ans plus tard l'entreprise compte
cinq salariés et jouit d'une belle
notoriété
il faut sortir de sa zone de confort
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas être trop
ambitieux mais faut être quand même
assez ambitieux pour essayer de de faire
des choses qui n'ont pas été vues avant
un petit peu bousculer les lignes pour
sortir du lot tout simplement si la
france compte une centaine de maisons
d'édition elles sont peu nombreuses à
tirer leur épingle du jeu
pourtant le marché est juteux il peser
en 2010 7 475 millions d'euros
je le disais 1 112 millions de boîtes de
jeux vendus en france c'est 87% des
français qui jouent aux jeux de société
et et c'est 100% des bories quand il est
franc comtois qui sont derrière alex
pour savoir quel est le dernier jeu vous
allez nous présenter que vous nous avez
réservé pour passer des vacances
sereines
à moins de 15 euros ça sympa exactement
à moins de 15 euros une petite boîte qui
s'appelle lindisfarne qui est aussi un
jeu dans une petite maison d'édition
toulousaine cette fois mais qui ont fait
un très très bon petit jeu de viking ou
en fait on va plus c'est moins familiale
on n'est plus sûr d un jeu avec gros
joueurs comme moi à la entre adultes
mais c'est un jeu sympa où on va faire
des raids de clan
king et on va on va devoir collectionner
des cartes et à la fin on va se faire
des superbes des superbes fresques
vikings qui vont nous rapporter des
points suivant les endroits où de la
planète qu'on a qu'on a sur lesquels on
a exécuté ses raids franchement c'est un
super jeu très simple moins de 15 euros
2 à 4 joueurs à partir de 12 13 ans
allez on récapitule vite pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent
on à la piscine avec loana et sabrina
ops et plouf partie adore argh excellent
2 à 4 joueurs à partir de 8 ans qui café
les kaka sur le sait très bien
3 3 6 joueurs à partir de 6 ans et
lindisfarne eux deux à quatre joueurs
on n'est plus sûr du 12 14 ans